okay the david pakman show subreddit is
a great place to chat with and discuss
politics with other David Pakman show
viewers now more than 11,000 of you
subscribed at david pakman.com slash
reddit i always say in videos that I
know are going to get people responding
to things I did not say watch the video
first and then comment watch the video
first and then comment and unfortunately
someone showed up on our subreddit and
posted about my recent Iran Trump
Venezuela Russia Putin video has Pakman
completely lost it Trump has to attack
Iran to proof he is not putting Russia's
interest before America's and of course
I didn't say any of that and this is
clearly someone who either didn't watch
the video or didn't understand it or
understood it and is pretending not to
have understood it I am NOT saying there
is any kind of conspiracy between Donald
Trump and Putin personally for Trump to
take foreign policy actions that Putin
has dictated to him it was a zoomed out
view of in the end Trump is deferring or
ending up with the foreign policy
decisions that protect Russia's
interests or would be the decisions
Putin would prefer that is as far as I
went it was a correlation discussion not
a causation discussion please watch the
videos before responding that should
just be a rule also on the david pakman
show subreddit yes somebody found images
and video of when I produced a
basketball skills video I was not the
instructor he will be glad to know but I
did play the defender and sometimes
offensive player to help the instructor
this is when I produced videos for
expert village and how I was like 22
years old and if you want to see
something really funny you can find this
on our subreddit you can also find it
easily if you follow me on instagram at
david pakman it is me holding a
basketball helping out in the production
of these basketball basics videos and it
is pretty funny and listen at 22 that
was it was good money for producing
those instructional videos I'm glad that
I did it check those out and thanks to
everybody who has been screenshotting
the funniest moments from the videos
really appreciate waking up every day
and seeing that on the subreddit join
the discussion at david pakman.com slash
our EDD IT